- Hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is #podSessions.
Pretty much my favorite
pillar type that I've created
in the last year or two,
but I don't get to do often,
'cause you know first I like
mixing up the guests I have,
the format if you're listening
or watching for the first
time is three guests and I.
And we just kinda shoot the shit,
talk about different stuff,
people that I have context for,
either I'm watching
very carefully from afar
or actually know.
All three here, I
actually know pretty well,
two I've met several times
in person, and one I've,
I've interacted with
you the most actually,
but we haven't met, and I'm
glad we finally did that.
And so I'm gonna let them
introduce themselves,
one minute bio-stories,
who they are, what they do,
and maybe a little fun fact,
and then we're gonna get into the show
and I'm gonna talk about some topics
and then also interject my
context of why I love them,
or admire them, or am curious about them,
or maybe dislike them.
I might be sand-baggin'
somebody right now, who knows.
But why don't we start with
the lady to my left first.
- Alright, I'm Erika Nardini.
I'm the CEO of Barstool Sports.
I've been at Barstool for two years.
We've taken the company
from 12 people and very small investment
to over a hundred million
dollar evaluation,
and we're becoming a
juggernaut in the men's space.
Prior to that I had a
company called Backstage,
where I really sought
to connect music artists
and their fans directly.
I hate disintermediation
and I thought that artists
should be able to own their
data, connect with their fans,
have an LTV type
relationship, and ultimately--
- Lifetime value for all the kids at home.
- Yep, yep.
And ultimately to be
able to know your fans
and connect with them
directly which is something
I've always been really passionate about.
Was the CMO of AOL, worked at a bunch
of big digital media companies,
started my career thinking
I was gonna be a lawyer,
which definitely did not happen.
- Now did you,
when you tell people
you're the CEO of Barstool,
which is known for not only
being a young male brand,
but like--
Edgy.
- Yeah, like it's like
the only thing out there
that I feel like, oh I could,
like it's real edgy.
- Yeah.
- Like are people like,
"Get the fuck out here" when you say it?
Do some people actually think--
- Yeah it's shocking.
- Like if you're just
hanging out in real life,
do some people actually
think you're joking,
and making a joke, and then they're like,
"No really, but what?"
- Yeah.
- I would believe that.
Like if I didn't know you and know how,
and like really know how badass you are,
but also just know that you were,
and I was like at a dinner conference
and everyone went around.
I'd be like, oh that's funny.
- That's funny yeah.
I think I'm a curiosity
in the whole mix of it,
because people wouldn't expect a woman
to be a CEO of Barstool.
I love Barstool, I'm
super proud to work there,
was a huge fan of Barstool.
Built a lot of Backstage
based on Barstool,
to be honest with you.
- Because you know the underlining truth,
not the kind of like,
the makeup that people get upset about.
Whether somebody curses or is raunchy.
- I think we live in an outrage society.
I think the pressure to be PC is just--
- [Gary] Overwhelming.
- Overwhelming.
And it's strangling.
- Understood.
- And the judgment that
comes with that is punitive.
And we are an agenda-less brand
that just cares about
making its audience laugh.
And we intimately get that audience.
That's what I love about it.
- Thanks for doing this.
- [Erika] Thank you.
- Go ahead, my man.
- My name's Reezy.
- Do you think it's funny
that I always say Rezzy?
- No, it's always, you said
you were a poor student, so.
(laughing)
- It's true.
He's right.
By the way, I don't know if you saw this,
yesterday I put out a piece of content,
oh, I didn't put it out
on my Instagram yet,
the I suck video?
I made a video in 2008 that said I suck,
and one of the examples
of me saying that I suck
is I suck at pronunciating and
saying things the right way.
'Cause in the wine world,
when I was doing Wine Library TV,
I would get these hate emails from Italy
and be like, "It's Barolo, not burrala."
People would get so pissed at me.
And literally I haven't
had that feeling for years
until I started to giving you daps
in the wrong pronunciation.
- So apparently knowing that two vowels
followed by a consanant is a long vowel
doesn't really matter in
the grand scheme of things.
- Yeah, you ready for this?
I had never heard, is that true?
I've never heard that in my life.
- Two vowels is always long
when followed by a consanent.
- Yeah I don't even know
what a fucking consanent is.
- It's a non-vowel.
But anyways.
Yeah, I go by Reezy.
I grew up super poor.
Food stamps, welfare,
government healthcare.
I never knew anyone that owned a business,
had a nice car, no one in my
family graudated high school,
owned a house, nothing.
I was homeless.
I lived in hotels.
I dropped outta highschool in 10th grade.
Had a kid, got married when I was 16.
Still married 18 years later.
13 years ago I found out
about selling books on Amazon.
And within a year--
- How?
Somebody said something somewhere?
- I was already into
Ebay because they were
running commercials on
TV when I was like 14.
So I sold everything I could,
and I was an avid reader.
One day I sold my Star
Wars books that I read.
And they went for, I
started them for a penny,
and they went for like
80% of the retail value,
which blew my mind.
Later on in life, I was in thrift stores,
I seen people with barcode
scanners scanning books.
I would ask them what are they doing.
They would clam up and they
would act like I was invisible.
Imagine an adult acting
like you're invisible.
So I was like oh they're
making a lot of fucking money.
(laughing)
And I'm technology minded.
They had barcode scanners.
- For all the people out there,
that's called street smarts.
Some of the things they
don't teach you in school
is when somebody clams up it's because
they're making a lot of money.
Keep going, my man.
Reezy.
- So they had a barcode
scanner and I was like
oh those are at least $100 to $300 bucks,
so they gotta be making some money.
So I drilled into it.
YouTube wasn't out yet, the iPhone--
- Hold on, that just made me smile.
Hold on, I gotta stop you,
'cause that just makes me smile, too.
Just thinking about your
psychology at that point.
Be like, "Yo, they're really on,
"because they got the barcode,"
you know, that's amazing.
Keep going.
- So smartphones weren't out yet.
iPhone wasn't out yet.
YouTube wasn't out yet.
There was no Reezy Resells.
There was no books I could read.
I exhausted my Google-fu trying
to figure out what it was.
And I couldn't figure out how
they were doing the books.
Eventually I just kept asking every person
I would run into and
finally some old lady,
she just told me everything right away.
And I was like thank you.
I ran home, looked it all up,
and then started selling
books the next day.
Apparently they were
selling them on Amazon.
I didn't even know what
Amazon was at the time.
This was 14 years ago.
And been selling books
and other things on Amazon
full time for the last 13 years
and I've sold over $5 million
gross in that time period.
About three years ago, I found
a little green and black book
called Crush It when I was
scanning books to sell,
and I scanned it, it
wasn't worth anything.
- Fuck!
(laughing)
- No offense.
But something about it just intrigued me.
It's like it reminded me of money.
It's called Crush It.
Like what douche names
their book Crush It?
(laughing)
Nobody ever.
And then I had just read the
Delivering Happiness book,
the Zappos book, and he has a
quote on the back of the book,
or whatever, so that sold me.
I went home, opened it,
read the whole thing.
I just sat down and read the whole thing.
And that's how I learned who you were.
And I was like holy shit.
I'd been doing social media.
I was like that guy that would
post pictures of his dinner
and get like 13 likes and be like, yeah,
fucking killing it.
And then I was like wait a minute.
I've been using it like a TV
and now I can push messages out.
And everything, the whole,
if you guys haven't read Crush It,
that's the fucking blueprint, right.
How can you, what do you wanna do,
how can you bring people around you.
Bring all your boys to
the yard or whatever.
And I was like shit, I
know how to sell shit.
And before that I was like
13 years of radio silence.
I didn't tell nobody shit.
I was clamming up on people.
And as soon as I started sharing,
I started making more money.
People were like, "Oh Reezy,
"how come you don't go
to the Factory Outlet
"and sell Nikes on Amazon?"
And I was like you can
sell Nikes on Amazon?
(laughing)
I was like holy,
they were like, "How come
you don't sell DVDs?"
I was like you can sell DVDs?
I was super--
- When are people gonna realize
doing the right thing is the right thing?
Never?
- I don't know, it's hard.
For me I grew up in a
really selfish family.
Not religious.
Just super selfish.
And then through following your blueprint
and helping other people,
which totally started out as
a selfish thing in the beginning.
I wanted to be a YouTuber.
I wanted to get my moment or whatever.
People start texting me,
"Hey, we're in Disneyland
right now with the family,
"and I never thought I would
be able to take my kids
"to Disneyland, but
because of what you did,
"we're able to have nice things now."
Or, "My husband lost his job.
"They canned him.
"And our family's thriving
because of your free content
"that you put out helped
us to achieve stuff."
And I get messages like that every day.
And like you said, well you say,
what do you say, it's like oxygen?
I say it's like crack.
Not that I know what crack is.
But like, I mean, I've
never experienced it.
But you know what I mean?
It's like instense, right?
- It's a high.
- There's nothing more.
Do you know what happens if
you take too much oxygen?
It's a high.
- Yeah.
And then just real quick to wrap it up.
When you started the 2017 flip challenge.
'Cause I stopped watching
your content a long time ago,
as you instructed me.
You get me sometimes on
Instagram and Facebook
with the short form.
- I can still sneak in once in a while.
- Right.
When the 2017 flip challenge started,
my phone started blowing up.
And all my boys were texting me like,
"Bro, he put you on."
And I'm like what?
'Cause you had mentioned me before.
But this was like you guys
had clips from my Snapchat
on there and I was like, holy shit,
that's two months ago.
So someone at Vayner was
watching my Snap two months ago.
- Not somebody, my guy.
- It was you?
- Well I don't watch content,
I'm always watching what's happening.
I don't watch anything.
I'm watching reaction.
I don't consume any Barstool.
This is real.
None.
I've never consummed any of Pat McAfee,
KFC, none.
But I know Barstool's
the most important thing
going on in sports.
'Cause I consume people.
I've never consumed a
single thing of yours.
I've consumed people taking a screenshot
of your YouTube with
fucking you with boxes.
What I know about your visually is like
boxes in the background of your garage
'cause it was a still shot
of somebody being like,
"Yo, Gary, you like flipping
stuff in garage sales.
"This guy likes flipping stuff."
You know what I mean?
And then you were emailing me like,
"Hey, Crush It helped me."
And it was very nice.
I read all my comments.
And I read culture.
Thus I can put two and two together.
So when I decided to do it,
because you know the reason that happened
was 'cause of Breakfast Club.
I went on Breakfast Club the first time.
I'm doing my thing.
And DJ Envy's like, "Yo, this is all fun,
"motivational guy."
You know Charlamagne was
like, "Gary Vee's the shit."
But Envy at that point was like,
"Yo, prove it to me."
He's like, "So give us
a real piece of advice
"for the people listening
that don't have--
- And you went on the Dollar Tree rant.
- I will always go to,
every time people ask me what
would happen if I lose it all,
I go right back to the Dollar
Tree, garage sales, Goodwill.
Because I can go from
zero to a million in cash
if I got dropped in, if
my face fell off my body
like that Travolta, Nicolas Cage, right?
And now I'm like a Latina woman tomorrow.
- You've got a plan.
- I can go from zero to a million easy.
Because the high I get,
do you know I found this
Thundercat at a garage sale
on Saturday a year ago at
12:45 p.m. of a garage sale
on a table in package for a dollar.
- [Reezy] They were sleeping.
- They weren't sleeping.
Everyone was sleeping.
This shit's supposed to
sell at six in the morning
if it's on a table for a
dollar at a garage sale.
Like when you know, you know.
- Is it original?
- Of course it's original.
- Damn.
You know, too, right,
those are the toys you had.
- That's right.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- I know 80s toys like, fuck
man, you don't even know how.
- 80s toys are the best.
- And I know like Rainbow Brite
and fucking My Little Ponies.
Like I'll tell you the name of the fucking
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
I'm fucking deep.
Anyway, so that's what you did.
- So, yeah.
- The phone blows up.
- When you started the 2017--
- [Gary] Flip challenge.
- I was like oh he's
talking about my shit now.
Now I can really get in the
comments and help people.
But before the 2017 flip challenge,
what kinda really started
our love affair was
you were live streaming
the eight hour live stream.
- That's right and you showed in
and I was like how many
books did you sell?
I remember that.
- You were streaming on three platforms,
Periscope, Facebook, and
Meerkat, which is dead now.
I couldn't get on Periscope,
I couldn't get on Facebook.
Literally one wouldn't let me on,
the other one wouldn't let me comment,
and all I wanted to do was comment.
And so I took the third door.
I went on Meerkat.
And then I had my comment ready to paste,
and I was just waiting,
waiting and waiting.
And everyone, and there was this lull
where you like got all
close to the screen.
And I was like boom!
Posted it, and then you read it,
and it was all out loud and
you had a good reaction.
And then I ripped it off of Meerkat,
and I asked you if I could
use it for my YouTube intro.
- I said yes, and that was it man.
I'm glad you're here.
Alex.
- My name's Alex.
I wrote The Third Door
and it's about my journey
the past seven years tracking down
some of the world's
most successful people,
figuring out how they
launched their careers.
So tracking down for business Bill Gates,
music, Lady Gaga, science,
Jane Goodall, Maya Angelou,
Jessica Alba, Larry King,
Quincy Jones, Steve Wozniak,
and it's been this wild adventure.
And a fun fact, which Gary knows,
is the whole journey
started when I was trying to
fund the adventure, I was 18 years old.
I was buried in student loan debt,
I was all out of bar mitzvah cash.
So there had to be a way
to make some quick money.
- Yo, when that bar mitzvah
cash goes, you stress.
(laughing)
- Well your back's up against the wall
when you have a dream and you
don't have bar mitzvah cash.
So I was like what am I gonna
do to make some quick money,
and I had this dream and I was on Facebook
the night before final exams
and I saw someone posting free tickets
to the Price is Right.
- This is crazy.
Keep going.
- My first thought was
what if I go on the show
and win some money to fund my dream.
But I had a problem.
I had never seen a full
episode of the show before,
plus I had finals in two days,
so I told myself not to do it.
But it was as if someone had
pulled a rope around my gut
and was pulling in that direction.
So that night I decided
to do the logical thing
and pull an all nighter to study,
but I didn't study for finals,
I studied how to hack The Price is Right,
and I went on the show the next day
and did this ridiculous strategy,
and ended up winning the
whole showcase showdown,
winning a sailboat, selling the sailboat,
and that's how I funded the book.
- One more time, for
the people in the back.
Put that last eight seconds one more time.
- So I pulled an all nighter,
studied how the show worked,
went the next day, won a sailboat,
sold the sailboat, and
that's how I funded the book.
- What was the insight?
- Yeah, what's the hack?
- Give us the hack on The
Price is Right at the time.
- Alright so this is how
The Price is Right works.
They make it look random like,
"Gary, come on down," as
if they pulled your name
out of a hat, right?
What I learned during my all
nighter of research is that
there's 300 people in the audience,
eight get called down, one wins.
So the odds, the hard odds
are getting from 300 to eight.
Once you're one of the
eight, I figured I could just
wing it from there.
And I realized there's a
producer who interviews
every single person in the
audience before the show goes on.
And then there's an undercover producer
who's planted in the audience
who confirms or denies the
original producer's selection.
- This is amazing.
- It was this wild experience,
and my hacking was less
Einstein and more Forest Gump,
but it worked really well.
- What did they want?
- They want someone who is just 100% in.
They want little Gary's--
- This is why I always get picked.
This made me think of the
Daily Show's first season
and I took my friend
Tokyo Joe, Joe Medica,
who I reference a bunch from college.
He's like a huge fan,
we're right outta college.
This is literally like
one of the only days
I did not work in my 20s.
This is true.
'Cause he came, love him so much.
We're gonna go see Jon Stewart.
I'm like whatever.
Joe wants to be an improv actor,
that's why he moved to Chicago.
He's gonna be on TV one day.
This, that, and the other thing.
We go in the audience,
and Jon Stewart comes up and
talks to me, because I'm just,
I would have been picked
for The Price is Right,
let's put it that way.
I'm incapable of not being fired up.
- So yeah, once I got the
money from The Price is Right
I was sort of like off to the races
and it took two years to
track down Bill Gates,
three years--
- Tell me about that transition.
So we're kinda now going
into interview form,
we've set some context.
You win a fucking sailboat,
you sell a sailboat,
you got a couple dollars.
What's the leap from I've got
a couple bucks from a sailboat
to I've gotta meet Bill Gates?
What was the thesis that you
were running on at that point?
Was it that if I can figure
out how the most successful
people, you clearly had a
brain that figured out how to
get on Price is Right,
were you always that
kind of social engineer
that you said if I can spend a lot of time
with successful people over
the course of a period of time,
I might figure out what actually works
and then I'll do that
for myself later in life?
- It started from a life crisis.
I was 18, I was a freshman in college
and I was spending every day
lying on my dorm room bed
staring up at the ceiling.
And Dunder said why.
- [Gary] 'Cause you resented it?
- It wasn't that I hated it.
It was that I am the
son of Jewish immigrants
which pretty much means
I came out of the womb,
my mom cradled me in her arms
and then she stamped MD on my ass
and sent me on my way.
Like different childhood than you.
- No question.
- Like the doctor track, 100%.
- Listen, I'm glad you're here,
and I'm glad we're doing this podcast,
'cause it's gonna create some clarity.
When I talk about being grateful, right,
think about you two talking
about your backgrounds,
different things but two things
that make me say I'm grateful for mine,
because I did have parents,
both parent situations have ramifications
that I worry about.
Which is either a tough scene,
or it's not a tough scene,
but there's an expectation
on the child that doesn't take
the child into consideration.
The fact that my mom took
me into consideration,
watched me and then decided,
okay, you'll be an entrepreneur,
not that she used that terminology.
Watched my brother AJ, I
really changed up the game
on my mom 'cause she
looked at my brother AJ
and said oh you're gonna be a lawyer.
That means you'll be a good student.
I swooped in 'cause I was older,
I was like fuck lawyer
shit, as you understand,
I was like, you're gonna
be an entrepreneur.
Be he was kind of like half.
I'm just grateful, and so that,
you know, a lot of people
are listening right now
and they understand Reezy, right.
They understand being
a minority, a female,
not coming from nothing,
that's understandable.
We do not talk about in our society
the people that I actually have equal,
let me say it now and
people can get mad at me.
Just because I know what
depression looks like.
We're judging happiness on the outside.
We have not started the conversation
on happiness on the inside.
And when we get to the conversation of
happiness on the inside, I
know the people in this room,
some of the people they know,
the people that are the
most unhappy on the inside
are the ones that have too much.
And it is, I get it, and
you can judge me now.
I'll see you in 80 years.
When people talk about,
you know, privilege.
They talk about all the right things.
White privilege, yes.
Male privilege, yes.
Gary Vaynerchuck's point
of view on privilege,
the right mindset.
You want real privilege?
Get born with good mental DNA
and be in good mental DNA environment.
Because having nothing,
or being stamped that you need to be an
engineer, lawyer, or doctor from the get,
is adversity.
And it's going to lead
to either really bad shit
or really great shit.
And my content on a daily basis,
is to help somebody who's on
the path of really bad shit
find a curve ball to start
the process of being in really good shit.
'Cause it's a kissing cousin.
You are literally gonna be completely
devastatingly unhappy and
have a piece of shit life
or completely dominate.
The delta is enormous.
Alex, I apologize.
So you have an MD?
- Well you don't apologize
'cause you actually teed it up perfectly
because what your content is,
I was 18 years old, a freshman in college,
the pre-med of pre-meds.
But I'm looking at this
stack of biology books
feeling like they're
sucking the life outta me.
So then I'm wondering
maybe I'm not on my path.
Maybe I'm on a path somebody placed me on
and I'm just rolling down.
So now I'm going through this life crisis,
I'm watching your videos.
Literally, 18 years old,
two months into college
in my study rooms on a Friday night.
All my friends are at a fraternity party.
I'm up there watching one of your keynotes
for the first time.
And I swear, man, I will
never forget that night
'cause my dad called me like five times
and I didn't answer
because for the first time
I was realizing maybe this isn't my path.
So now not only do I not
know what I wanna do,
I don't know all the people I looked up to
how they did it.
How did Bill Gates sell
his first piece of software
out of his dorm room when
nobody knew his name.
How did Spielberg become
the youngest director
in Hollywood history when he's
rejected from film school.
These are the things they
don't teach you in school.
So in my pain and in my confusion
I had a very naive idea of
well why don't I just call up Bill Gates
and interview him myself.
I thought it would take three months.
Seven years later it just came out.
- Unbelievable.
Good for you, man.
- Thank you man.
And thank you for all
that advice along the way.
- My pleasure, my pleasure.
Let's go back around.
What is the most
interesting thing in culture
in the world going on right now
that doesn't have to do with Barstool?
Like what are you watching?
Is there a restaurant that
has an $800 cheeseburger?
Are you obsessed?
I'm gonna preface it.
What are you obsessed with right now
that you're watching
that's happening out there?
I've come to realize, oh,
I'm an anthropologist.
It's amazing who I think I am now.
Literally I just decided this a week ago.
The last week I'm like, oh,
those people that go to
the jungle for four years
to study the red-beaked baboon,
that's me, I just do that with people.
So I'm always watching, that's my love.
I always find it funny 'cause I'm gonna
interrupt you guys 10 times
here and everybody's like
you're not a listener,
you're such an asshole,
stop interrupting people.
I'm like man I'm such a listener,
it's just I listen differently.
I'm watching for cues, that's
what I've done my whole life.
So there's always things that
are catching my attention.
Like for example if this
was a year and a half ago
I'd be like this woman
Cardi B's got my attention,
I've never listened to her.
I didn't listen to a single Cardi B song
before I read over 100,000
comments about Cardi B.
- [Man] Wow.
- Yeah, that's weird.
I've now realized and
I'm articulating it more
'cause maybe it's gonna help
somebody figure out shit.
But that's kind of like heady,
what about like, what are
you obsessed with right now?
Like a new drink, a new
t-shirt, a new show,
your nephew's new girlfriend.
Give me something here.
- Okay, I'm obsessed with a lot of things.
I'm obsessed with going into nail salons
and seeing what they are watching.
- The default show.
- What is the default
show in a nail salon.
- Is it politics or is like
daytime, like Steve Harvey?
- The best ones are either
Korean or Chinese television.
- Love it.
- Korean and Chinese
television is fascinating.
Because it's YouTube, it's young,
there's a lot of characters,
they're doing stupid shit.
And the energy is insane.
I don't like it when
the nail salon runs like
cheapo, fake news station,
where it's like the
weather, innocuous content.
But if you go to--
- Will you like walk in?
- I just walk in to just see.
- Peep and you're out?
- And then leave, yeah.
'Cause it's New York City so you can,
there's like 16 nail salons.
- [Gary] Love that.
- The other thing is Irish bars.
I love Irish bars.
So I always walk into,
like I walked over here.
- McGilley's!
- Yeah, McGilley's.
I'm like okay, you walk
in, like who's there,
what's on the television,
what are they serving?
- There's a lot of proper
football on those televisions.
- Proper football, that's right.
- There's a lot of that.
- Especially in the morning.
- Reezy.
- So nothing as weird as
stalking the nail salon
choice television shows.
- [Gary] That was fucking amazing.
- I'm super into coffee,
specifically espresso.
I have a machine at home.
- Is it fancy?
- Yeah, super fancy.
But it's like I got it for cheap on eBay.
I repaired it, it's sick.
- Real quick, of course you did that.
But guys these espresso
machines are expensive.
- I don't even, yeah.
- I just found out about this.
I don't know if people know about this.
- [Erika] Thousands and
thousands of dollars.
- $20,000 dollars on an espresso machine.
- On a personal one?
- Yeah, I didn't know this.
- What does the cost do?
Like what makes it better?
- So it's just all about like...
- The name on the machine.
Boom!
- No, no, not really.
It's all about consistency, right.
- [Erika] The steam is a little hotter.
- Your Nespresso, that's
just like some bullshit.
- Yeah, that's like a Toyota.
- Like whatever.
- You're into the Maserati shit, right?
- It's all, it's like manual,
you know you grind the
coffee, expensive grinder.
The particle size of
the coffee is uniform.
- Do you find this cathartic?
- Is it ritual do you feel like?
- I drink a lot of
coffee, so I do take pride
in knowing what's going into it.
I used to drink eight cups of coffee a day
and my boy Chris Baka, who is like
a nationally ranked barista.
He owns this coffee that I
brought for the team or whatever.
He would see me coming, he'd be like,
"Dude you drink like eight
cups of coffee a day.
"Have you ever tried espresso?"
And I was like no what's espresso?
And he was like, "Well,
it's like four to six ounces
"of coffee caffeine wise,
but in a one ounce package.
So you can get all your caffeine you need
but you have a lot less acidic
beverage in your stomach.
So for me it just started
out with hacking it.
Like cool, I'll have
less of a stomach ache
and I'll be just as jacked up.
And then I became enamored with it,
to learn like, oh--
- Yeah, it became like a wine thing.
100%
- [Reezy] Exactly, I shit you not.
- No, it's the same thing.
- When I started seeing, like going back
into the old wine content,
because you started
doing the brown bag stuff, so I was like
I like this shit so I started
watching the old shit.
And I realized that I knew dick about
the finer things in life
until I started doing,
food wise or whatever, until
I started doing the coffee
because it's like where is it from,
how is it roasted--
- And then it opens up the whole world.
- How is it prepared,
what does it taste like,
butter toffee, like fungus, like whatever.
- It's cool right?
- It's insane.
- And that's what gets
you into sushi or oysters,
it just opens up the whole world.
- Do you think it tastes
better if you buy it?
Like I can't, it doesn't matter how good
whatever machine, I don't
have a good machine,
so that's probably part of it.
But I have to buy coffee, it
tastes better if I buy it.
- Oh, then you make it?
- Yes.
- That's interesting.
- I think in 10 minutes I can teach you
how to make the best cup
of coffee in your house.
- That's in the next
episode of #podSessions.
Alex?
- I am obsessed, especially the past year,
with standup comedy.
- Okay, that makes sense?
You're gonna do that, aren't you?
Like I know you do it.
Like are you--
- [Alex] I do it in keynotes.
- I know, are you gonna really do it?
- It's like an alter ego fantasy.
Just like being a rapper.
- I know you well enough to know this.
Do you think you're gonna do it?
- Yeah, I'll fuck around with it.
- Yeah, I thought so too.
You gotta give it, you have enough--
- I've never said that
out loud, by the way.
- [Gary] I believe you.
- Congratulations.
All my friends have asked and I'm like no.
- I know, and I knew that
I could get you to say
'cause I knew that you
knew you couldn't trick me.
I really, really think
you will and here's why.
I know you just enough to know this.
There's too much upside
and not enough downside.
- Hmm.
- That's why you're gonna do it.
It's a hack.
- And it's fun as shit.
- There's too much upside.
It's why I did the sneaker deal.
The reason I did the K-Swiss sneaker deal
was it was too much upside
with not enough downside.
If it worked, and it's kind of like
doing its thing right now and I gotta
keep building momentum, then it's like,
"Wow, that's crazy that he
pulled that off, the economics."
God forbid the whole genre goes
then I'm the fucking
Jordans of the whole thing.
Fuck you, Michael Jordan.
Right, that whole thing.
If it didn't work, what funny fodder
like nine years from now where like
I'm being interviewed they're like,
"Okay, look, you're really successful,
"before we start this fireside chat,
"can we go back to 2017?
"What the fuck were you
thinking about doing a sneaker?"
Too much upside with not enough downside.
That's why I think you're gonna do it.
If you're watching Seinfeld right now
on Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee
I think in 50 years
we'll look back and say
he was a fucking
philosopher, not a comedian.
- Oh, I understand.
- I fully think, and he's a craftsman too.
- Listen, I have a lot
of respect for Seinfeld.
I wouldn't call myself
a huge Seinfeld fan.
I will say this because
I adore Hasan Minhaj,
I watched that episode
'cause of Hasan Minhaj,
and I was super disappointed
in Seinfeld's inability
to, it's funny, I cut people
off because we don't edit.
They film all day, they edit.
Really easy to make it seem
like nobody's getting cut off.
I thought that was a super awkward episode
and it made me think that I was surprised
that he wasn't capable of
adjusting to the guest.
I thought the Kate McKinnon,
which I also watched,
it came natural, thus it was great.
The Hasan Minhaj, it didn't come natural,
and I thought it was really bad.
Thoughts.
- I think that your
keynotes are standup comedy.
- I do too.
- And I think with Seinfeld,
especially your Q&As.
That's where you get the most stand up,
when I see it come out of you.
And I think with Seinfeld and
Hasan Minhaj, that episode,
it was surface and it
could have gone deeper.
I've seen other stuff with Hasan
like the White House
Correspondents Dinner.
- Both.
I think it was--
- Styles make fights.
(mumbling)
I love you for, give me something.
You know how many people never ever react
when I use that analogy.
That's a--
- [Alex] Where's that from?
- It's a, you have to be
an old school boxing guy.
Like the guys with cigars,
Burt Sugar was the icon,
he passed away several years ago.
Like a 1957's Irish bar, three cigars,
a fight's on, it's two great fighters,
and everyone's bored and one guy's
gonna look at the other guy and go,
"Styles make fights."
And it's like my life philosophy.
When people walk in here
and quit VaynerMedia
and tell me I'm a dick,
I say in my brain, styles make fights.
This kid's a great kid.
VaynerMedia's got great intent.
Styles make fights.
It didn't click.
At this moment at this
time, it didn't click.
They're not a dick.
Vayner's not a bad place.
Styles make fights.
And that's what I, I was watching it,
and like six minutes, like two seconds in,
but like six minutes in I'm
like fuck styles make fights.
- [Erika] It's true.
- Pacquiao, Mayweather.
- That's the most extreme styles.
- Styles make fights.
And what's funny is like, it depends,
it's just styles make fights.
Micky Ward, Arturo Gatti.
Two solid to below average fighters,
depending on how you wanna argue it.
But the two of them made
magic over three fights.
If literally you love sports,
or if you love theater, go Google
Arturo Gatti, Micky Ward,
and watch those three fights.
You'll shit.
Better than the ridiculousness
of a Rocky fight and drama
in real life.
It's actually crazy.
And I know a lot of
you aren't boxing fans.
UFC'd out.
Lotta you kids don't like
either or whatever, or older.
Go watch 'em.
It's fucking theater.
Erika what's happening in sports.
- There's a ton.
So speaking of that, we bought
a boxing promoter last October
called Rough and Rowdy.
And it is all styles makes fights.
- This is your pay-per-view shit, right?
- Right, amateur fighters.
- I'm so obsessed with you.
- It's awesome, so fun.
- You're so smart.
I just want people to know
that I think you're smart.
And I think nobody's smart.
- Thank you.
I think you're smart too.
(laughing)
- [Reezy] Nobody.
- I'm blown away by what
you guys have done there.
People don't get, it's really almost like,
you know what influencers
have done to real celebrities?
I think that's what you're
gonna do to mainstream fighting.
- [Erika] Yeah, to media.
- 100%.
- But what's amazing, why
I'm obsessed with it--
- But please tell everybody,
I don't know what you've publicly
said about numbers or not
from a success standpoint,
really quick 'cause I don't
think a lot of people know
what we're talking about.
You did a pay-per-view on the internet.
- So we bought a boxing promoter.
Dave Portnoy, the founder
of Barstool, huge visionary,
single best promoter
I've ever met in my life,
went and did a video
in 2012 on this weirdo
West Virginia boxing promoter
where he just had guys from West Virginia
in a high school basketball gym
beat the shit out of each other.
- You know, the street
fights that I watch,
I consume no content.
The only thing that catches
me still to this day
is two random people fist
fighting on Instagram or YouTube.
- Totally, it's a train wreck.
You cannot look away.
- I love it the most.
'Cause the high that I get
from a natural knock out,
a one punch knock out,
I've not been able, the only,
sports, which I'm obsessed with.
Here's the thing, back to highs
that we mentioned earlier,
that get me from zero,
the high is going from zero to a thousand.
A one punch knock out,
a overtime scoring goal.
Playoff hockey, overtime scoring goal,
I mean, I don't even care about hockey
for a long time now 'cause
the Rangers won in 94.
My son's starting to get into sports,
so I make him consume everything.
A playoff hockey game,
'cause it's over in a blink.
It's over in a blink.
It's like life, it's
why I love life so much.
Over in a blink.
- Yep.
But then there's also like
pride and honor and class.
- The backstory.
- The fuck you, I'm gonna win.
Like it's all of that.
So Net Net, we put
together this boxing event.
- It was crazy.
- And it's for an internet consuming era.
It's 30 fights, three one minute rounds.
It goes very, very, very fast.
So that's my opinion of sports.
- When's your next one?
- Next Sunday.
So Youngstown, Ohio.
- How many have you done?
- We have done, this
is Rough N' Rowdy five.
So we've done five.
Next Sunday.
I wanna watch it.
Tyler, get my calendar right.
- Live from Youngstown, Ohio,
which is the birthplace
of boxing in the U.S.
Gonna be awesome, grit, city of grit.
- [Gary] Love it.
- We did, we have a marquis fight
between a cop and a skateboarder,
and the cop is awesome.
A guy named Ryan Young.
Gave us full access.
We rode around with him in the car.
- [Gary] 24/7.
- 24/7.
And he got fired.
- Who's the skater?
- The skateboarder?
- Yeah.
I'm a skateboarder, guys.
- [Erika] He's like a local--
- He got fired for doing it?
- Got fired because he was
in a Barstool Sports video.
- Is he looking for a job?
- We're gonna make him whole
for the next two years.
- I love you so much.
Guys I'm telling you,
like we were putting this together.
Alex has been hitting me up,
he's like "Yo I need to promote my book,"
I fucking love the hustle.
Reezy's been hitting
me up for three years.
Like, "Yo, can I get a
fucking physical cosign?
"I appreciate the verbal cosigns."
So I knew I wanted to do a #podSessions,
'cause I'm running out of time before,
like I gotta fit a lotta
stuff in the next three weeks.
So I was like cool,
time for a #podSessions.
And I'm like alright, these
two fucking dick faces,
who should I, who can I
round out this show with
that is so gnarly that's just gonna make
this whole thing fun to look back at.
And that's why I texted you.
- That's so nice.
- Super into you.
- So nice.
- Okay, Reezy, what's the
best little flip you've had,
whether it's a book or something.
Like, listen, nothing gets a high for me
like a single micro-flip.
I actually don't wanna
hear about you buying out
a warehouse and making 80k.
- No, no, no, I got you.
- I'm talking about one book,
one scan, where I don't even know what
you're currently up to on the flip.
- It's not a book.
- I didn't think it would be.
- The best single item I ever flipped.
- No, no, I don't want historics.
We'll go to that too.
In the last 60 days,
'cause I assume you're
still a practitioner,
or are you now just a
fucking pontificator?
- No, no, no.
- Respect.
So what have you flipped
in the last 60, 70, 80 days
that was just like a funny one-off.
I want some random shit you were like--
- It's super boring
because I sell mostly books
- [Gary] No, no, I love this shit.
- I sell mostly books
so I've definitely sold
several $300 books in the last month
that I bought for a quarter.
- Cool, so I need this.
- How do you know what they're
great when you buy them?
- He scans the fuck out of them.
- So we have the entire Amazon--
- [Erika] You have a $300 scanner.
- Yeah, well they're cheaper now.
Technology caught up.
And we have smartphones.
So I have the entire database
of Amazon in my phone,
and then I scan it with the barcode.
I don't need wifi, I don't need-
- Ready for this, ready for this?
Not only does he have
a sense of the price,
but he has a sense of the demand.
- So you know the market?
- Yeah, and I wanted to give
this to the audience too,
it's called Sales Rank on Amazon.
It's the number that indicates
how well something sells.
And they're separate for each category.
So in books the number
one best selling book
has a sales rank of one.
And I'm sure like--
- Crushing It, it's probably Crushing It.
It's not.
- Well maybe on launch day.
Do you know what you
got up to on launch day?
- On launch day, six.
- That's fucking awesome.
- Can I ask a question?
- Two actually, I think.
- So Saturday mornings,
are you just prowling around yard sales?
I don't mean to be naive.
- Not anymore.
- [Reezy] Nah, I don't
do yard sales too much.
- He's VIP.
I do.
- You do.
Do you have staff that does that?
- I actually really, really enjoy it.
Like one of my favorite things is to just
look up completed sales on eBay.
- By the way, that is my--
- You just go, oh, marbles,
like I'm just basically copying.
Ooh, marbles are worth
money, oh mind blown.
You're like, oh people
collect vintage paper.
- It's the best.
- And you're like I saw some last week.
They were throwing it away.
- So have you created an
affiliate model on the,
'cause that's what I'm doing
with Barstool basically,
and I think that that's fascinating.
- [Gary] No, it's different.
- I am not good at monetizing
my audience or anything.
I still do my core business,
my business that I run
which I have a business partner with.
- [Gary] He's following the blueprint.
The smart one.
- And then I do my personal brand,
which makes me a little bit of money.
Like my YouTube video, there's links.
Like if you need a printer.
- He's doing my model.
- Go get the printer.
- He's super smart.
He's gonna get bigger
economics when he gets paid
$100,000 for one speech
than making an arm.
Got it?
- [Erika] Okay, fine, got it.
- I'm actually going to
London to speak in two weeks.
- He, like me, has economics elsewhere.
Thus isn't monetizing his audience.
Got it?
To build the attention
to monetize in the future
if he even chooses to.
What's gonna eventually
happen is he's gonna realize
the admiration's a bigger
high than the money,
and he's not gonna get to
even monetizing the audience.
- [Erika] Which is okay.
- Which is the best.
That's how you fuck it up
with legacy and everything.
- Because now, you know, last year,
people would hit me up for
sponsored YouTube videos
and I would tell 'em my price
and they would not even answer.
And now I tell 'em and
they pay me right away.
Might be raising the price soon.
- [Erika] Good for you.
- What's the best single, 300, ready?
'Cause I need people to hear this.
'Cause I'm obsessed, listen,
you know how passionate I am about this.
Authentically passionate.
I don't talk about anything
outside my normal stuff
other than a little bit of cosigning
some hip hop artists on the rise,
and a little bit of, and you've seen,
I've gotten really hot
on, 'cause, you know,
I'm getting 1,000 emails saying,
"Okay, Gary Vee, but I have no money."
So I went to the roguest place which is
cool, here's the new flip.
Craigslist free.
It's free.
You go and you take it.
It's fucking free.
Then you go to Facebook marketplace,
because the thing you
learn about Craigslist free
was he's as good as, books are small.
Craigslist free is bad 'cause shit is big.
It's like a chair and
fucking cinder block.
- [Erika] Totally.
- They still won't believe you though.
- Right.
So it's free.
So my thing is not arbing
on Amazon and Ebay,
which is what I would
recommend for his world
and the stuff I love.
But on Craigslist, the
flip is Amazon marketplace,
excuse me, Facebook marketplace.
You go and pick up a fucking hammock,
and then you list it for $30 on Facebook,
and you sell it in five minutes.
The reason so many people are
selling them in five minutes
is it's a supply and demand game.
Facebook marketplace
is still not saturated,
but Facebook is so at scale
that people are seeing shit.
- [Erika] The demand is there.
- Yes.
- It's clockwork.
There's so much free stuff
that like, for example,
we moved to a condo from our house
and we had a trampoline at our house.
Well we can't have a
trampoline at our condo
so I tried to sell it for
months before we moved.
No one bought it so I
gave it away for free
the day before we moved.
Free trampoline that I
only had for three months,
18 foot trampoline.
- [Gary] How much did you pay for it?
- Probably $350 at least.
- Love this.
- They got it for free and
you could easily sell that--
- [Gary] For 90.
- You have to wait it out,
you have to use better keywords,
you have to put it on a
different marketplace.
Treadmills, January, people are like,
"I'm gonna get fit."
They buy treadmills, they buy
freaking work out machines,
whatever they're called.
And then they do it for
like a month, gets dusty.
- [Gary] Then March comes along.
- Yeah.
Then it's on the free section
'cause no one's gonna buy a treadmill.
People buy a brand new treadmill.
- You need to be creating QVC.
Why haven't you done that?
- Listen, I've got.
Listen, why haven't I done that
is like the story of my life.
What do you want?
I can do it.
I'm so crippled by opportunity that,
like I can do everything.
What I think I'm doing right now,
and you might remember this
from the rant in past Backstage.
I'm building a machine
to let me do everything.
- [Erika] Yeah, of course.
- I'm gonna do fucking everything.
I'm just patient.
At 72 years old, I'm gonna
be like, yep, QVC (brrring).
T-shirt company (pshing).
New Facebook, fine.
I'm just building a fucking
Death Star and I'm gonna
pew, pew, pew.
I'm gonna destroy, you have to understand.
Vayner's gonna do everything.
I'm gonna fucking take over everything.
All of it.
- [Erika] Totally.
- Happily and everyone's
gonna be happy for me.
- [Erika] Yep.
- What's the, so this
25 cents to 300 bucks.
Here's why I'm very
passionate about this Reezy,
the most important.
There's all the people
that you and I think about
when we talk about this subject matter
that can literally go from being miserable
making $78,000 being the
regional manager of four restaurants
to making $109 flipping
Star Trek memorabilia
'cause they love it.
We know that's real, which is crazy.
I'm actually really focusing
on something very narrow lately
with my whole I've got no money, none.
And a 100 bucks is game changing.
Like literally, I mean, Tyler
you're the one that knows this
and some of my social
media team on the DMs,
this stuff is emotional.
- [Erika] Oh, totally.
- Making an extra 100 bucks
a month is like (brring).
And you know this, you
come from that dirt.
So I'm just like, man,
fucking Craigslist free,
if you're just raw and hungry.
Even if you're not raw and hungry.
Even if you wanna just
move outta your apartment.
If you don't give a
fuck about what people,
the problem is people
give a fuck what you,
you know why I'm crazy?
I'm now at where I'm at,
and I'm rolling up to garage sales,
and people are like,
"Gary Vee?"
And I'm still in garage
sale mode, I'm like
yo you wanna quarter for that?
And when you really don't give a fuck
about what people think, you know like,
I'm pulling up in like a Range Rover,
I don't know how expensive,
I don't even know
how much my cars are.
Like a car that I'm sure
is probably some money
and negotiating people with like
yo, fuck that 50 cents,
like 25 cents mother fuck.
When you don't care about what,
the biggest reason somebody broke as fuck
is not listening to my advice
is they care about what
other people think.
They're embarrassed to
go pick something up
and carry a chair on the bus
'cause they have no money
'cause they're worried
somebody's gonna look at them.
I want people judging me.
I want the chip on my shoulder.
Anyway, 25 cents to 300.
What is that?
Goodwill scan everything
and one of 'em's 300?
- Yeah, basically.
- Are they usually college books?
- So the best selling books
are non-fiction mostly.
Textbooks are the cream of the crop.
- Textbooks are the holy grab, right?
- For sure.
It's a huge scam.
If you've been to college,
you know that hurts.
It's like $250 books.
- So real quick on this
- [Alex] And you don't read it.
- [Reezy] Yeah.
- I know you do heavy
Goodwill, that kinda stuff.
Do you ever garage sale?
- I used to a lot but--
- I know why it's less
efficient than Goodwill
and other things, and church
sales, and book sales,
I get that.
Take me back to garage sale day.
Did you ever hit a mother lode where you
literally rolled up on like a professor
or like a former college admin
and there was like 88 textbooks.
Like AJ, my brother, right.
We have the story of, we were hard core,
we were so right about video games.
Like I love when people
are like, "Oh you're,"
like I just posted this article about
why I'm going all in on Twitch,
and my whole social media's like,
"Oh, I beat Gary Vee to something.
"You're so late, you suck."
And I'm laughing, I'm like, motherfucker,
I was buying video games
in 2000, like cartridges
because I thought they
would be memorabilia in 2030
when you were like fucking two, dick.
Like I'm not late, I'm
just entering what I enter.
So we were hard core video games.
We were so right, we used
to have like 100 Contras,
they were five back in the day.
They're like 45 now.
Like we nailed it, right.
If my dad didn't throw 'em all
away out of spite and anger
of us holding them there
it would have been like an incredible ROI.
What's really interesting to me
is we did have that one
day that we dreamed of.
We rolled up on a Friday afternoon,
which is (pshing) again,
to an old man that was 70,
which again, never has video games, right.
But somehow it must have
been his grandkid's stuff.
AJ finds a box with
unlimited rare RPG games,
like Ninja Gate and Trilogy,
and fucking MegaMan this,
literally AJ bought for $10 40 games
that was worth almost $3,000, $4,000.
Did you ever have that
in the textbook game?
- I rolled up at a Christian school
and they were completely closing down,
or they were selling everything,
I'm assuming they were closing.
- How'd you find that?
Was that Craigslist or the internet or
were you driving and saw a big sign?
- No.
- [Gary] You knew.
- I used an app called
Yard Sale Treasure Map.
- [Yeah] I know this story so well.
- It aggregates all the
different yard sales.
- Yard sale, garage sale,
I know all that shit.
- I don't remember 'cause I was
just going to a different one.
- [Gary] So you roll up.
- It wasn't as big of a
lick as it could have been
because it was an elementary school
so elementary school textbooks are not--
- [Gary] Are less.
- You know it's rare that
they're worth like $30.
I got like 500 books and you know like
$30 books I got like 20 copies of it.
So they weren't like $250 books.
- [Gary] And how much did you spend?
- I paid like a quarter
a book or something.
But it wasn't even about the money,
they were just happy
that I took all the books
because people were taking the desks,
people were taking the furniture,
they were like, "What are we
gonna do with all these books?"
I was like I'll take 'em.
- And so what did you have to do?
Did you have to go, did you
have a big enough vehicle?
- Just packed 'em in the
Subaru, multiple trips.
- Multiple trips.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Let me tell you about
one of mine back to paper,
which I learned along
the way was great too.
This is a great story that I
don't think I've ever told.
I was going to a Wine
Library business meeting in,
AJ was in high school
2005, in 2003 or four,
like at 2:30, go to this
restaurant, taste Wine,
buy for the store.
- [Man] Before you get into it,
Erika's gotta go in like five.
- Fine.
This story's too good.
- [Erika] Yeah, go on.
- I don't care if Erika
has to leave in the middle.
- [Erika] I'm not even with the story.
- I'm going to like 2:30
in Chatham, New Jersey
to fucking Serenade to
taste like 13 Rieslings
to buy one for Wine Library
and I see, I'm a little,
a hair, and I mean like
Erika has to go in five
minutes hair early, right.
And it's like garage sale today, Friday.
And Friday's are gangster because
a lot of the, the scale
comes on Saturday morning.
- [Reezy] People are still at work.
- Friday's at work.
And I'm like, fuck I'm going.
And one of these weird ones
where I said I can't go
and then at the last second,
so I kind of like had to
go, I went past the turn
and almost got into an accident.
And I roll up, I walk in,
and I see an old Huckaberry, what's that
hanna babera character?
Huck?
I don't know
- [Reezy] The bluish dog?
- Yes.
- [Reezy] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Huckleberry Finn, Huckleberry Hound.
- Hound, Huckleberry Hound.
So I saw a 1978 knickerbocker
Huckleberry Hound
nice condition, I'm like boom, got it.
Dollar, good, that's like $30,
I'm already pumped, right.
I go in the basement and I
see fucking boxes, and I mean
80 boxes.
And I roll up into it and it
is playbills from Broadway
at a scale that you couldn't believe.
From the 40s to the 80s.
- [Reezy] Wow.
- So I go and it's an estate sale
so I'm like, ah, I'm gonna get fucked.
'Cause you know estate sales blow
'cause they're more expensive.
I go how much?
They're like, "Well, 50 cents a piece."
I'm like how much do you
want for all of this to go,
all of it?
And I know no value, I'm not doing,
I'm a purist, I don't look shit up.
I still like jerk myself around.
If I was doing full-time,
I'd look up everything.
But I'm still, and back then
you couldn't look up this way.
No smartphones, we used to have to do it
on the fucking gut.
They go, "Well, what about $120?"
And I'm like what about $20.
And I'm like 20.
Like I tried to kinda do some
like Obi-Wan Kenobi shit.
Like I'm aggressive, it was 20.
They're like, "30 and it's yours."
I take it, I buy it.
I did have a cell phone,
yeah I had a cell phone.
Yes, I called Kabarna, what was his name?
Dave Barna, I called Dave Barna,
and I'm like yo, I'm sick, or I fucking,
and drove home to AJ to
take him outta high school
to look up all this shit.
Nonetheless, we made like a gadrillion.
And there was like 1940 baseball guides.
There was the fucking original
Pinocchio fucking movie.
- [Reezy] Wow.
- And the like Betty Davis
and fucking Judy Garland,
they were like 30, 40, 50.
25 cents for 300, I need
people to understand
who are listening right now.
Get a fucking scanner.
Like how much are these scanners now?
- Like $100, $150 refurbished.
$300 brand new.
- Alright, Tyler, this
is what we're gonna do.
We're gonna do something with Reezy.
We're gonna do a day, and
I'm just gonna give out
like fucking 50 of 'em.
Just gonna pick a day in
September when we get back,
just random, and we're
gonna do some sort of funny,
he's gonna tweet something cryptic,
and I'm gonna see who replies
and just fucking hit 'em hard.
Giving away fucking scanners.
- That's awesome.
Because this'll literally be,
you know, this will be me
giving people a fishing pole.
- [Erika] Mm hmm, that's right.
- And they're gonna fucking eat.
Erika you gotta bounce.
- [Erika] No, no, we're good, we're good.
- In two minutes, give me something good?
What do you want to talk about,
what are you thinking about?
What do you think about
when you hear this?
Do you like garage saling?
- I love garage sales.
- What's your garage sale game?
- I used to buy a lot of clothes on eBay.
- 'Cause you were like super
cool like retro, vintage.
- Retro, vintage, and cheap.
Retro, vintage, and cheap,
which is a good combination.
- And then that became cool.
You were ahead of the game.
- That became cool.
But then it became not cool, whatever.
But anyways, then it's
like hard to part with it.
But what do I like in garage sales?
I just like what people--
- [Gary] The scene, right?
- The shit.
What is going on in your life?
How'd you get here?
Who are you, what are you about?
What are you collecting?
How messy are you?
Are you a hoarder?
I love the psychology of it.
- [Reezy] We hope they're hoarders.
- Yeah, hoarders are great.
But it's funny.
Like I just cleaned out our garage
and put a bunch of shit in a dumpster.
And we had this lovely, weirdo
Spanish lady in our life.
- [Reezy] Where is this dumpster located?
(laughing)
- [Erika] Exactly, she
came over yesterday--
- Reezy, do you dumpster dive?
- [Reezy] No, but I've done it before.
- [Erika] I don't think it's a bad--
- Dude, I wanna go to a junkyard so bad.
- [Reezy] I just have not
had enough good luck from it.
- [Erika] You know what's funny?
- I would do it right now.
I'll fucking go in a dumpster.
I'm so weird.
I'm not scared of shit.
I'm fucking dirty as dirt.
I love the dirt.
- [Erika] But it's the reward of it.
I remember I grew up in,
I was born in Colorado--
- [Gary] Can you imagine, sorry go ahead.
- Sorry, no, go ahead.
But we had no money and my
parents furnished our house
from the dump, the dump was like--
- Could you imagine if I'm,
you know the dump that's really good
is behind shopping malls.
- [Reezy] Yes, sir.
- Because a lot of
times retailers do shit.
(mumbling)
I was just thinking could you imagine
'cause I'm now getting hyped
and I might get bored late
August on my vacation.
Could you imagine somewhere in Long Island
somebody driving into
a shopping center like
do their groceries and my
head pops out of a dumpster.
And they're like, "Was that Gary Vee?"
That's like how much--
- [Erika] It'd be a good video series.
- Alex, how's your book doing?
- It's doing great.
- When did it come out?
- Just about a month ago.
- Okay, tell the truth,
'cause this is what I love about you
and this is why I wanted you on the show.
Did it do as well in week one
as you thought it was gonna do?
Not what you hoped.
Like straight unemotional,
like my kid's not the
cutest all the time talk.
You have a lot of relationships.
I'm fascinated by when somebody
plays life the way you do
which is try to do the right thing,
have my own ambitions, pay
forward, build relationships.
I think the thing that
is always fascinating
about a kid or not a kid's first book,
especially when they're smart and
know how to ask for a right hook,
is who comes through and who doesn't.
You must have been so fascinated
in your first month or two
of the people in your mind.
You're like, oh, that socialite girl
is gonna put me on and is definitely
gonna do the selfie picture
because I've done nine
great things for her
and then she didn't.
Or when somebody came
through and bought 100
and did something rad
that you only met once.
Tell everybody who's listening
the fascination of that 10
years of being in the game,
seven years of being in the game,
and then writing a book
and going in for those right hooks
and who come through
and who didn't and why
and how it did.
- So, you're right.
Most fascinating thing.
You don't remember this at all.
But when I was 19 you gave me
three pieces of book advice
and one of them was bring
your expectations to zero.
And I remember I was
like that makes no sense.
And as I was gearing up this past year,
I was like if I don't do that
I'm gonna be fucking depressed.
I am super happy, man.
Dude, I could not be here and
I would still love you 100%.
'Cause the expectations zero.
- Brother, that's what I do all the time.
- But you reprogrammed me when I was 19.
You don't know that, though.
- What's amazing about that is for me,
the thing about that is
that is why I'm happy.
Literally everybody's unhappy
because they have
expectations from something.
The government, humans
in general, their mother,
their best friends,
the person they did all these things for.
You know how many fuckers
running around right now
do shit with some agenda on the backend,
and when that person doesn't
come through for them,
they're mad at the person,
but they were the piece of shit
for trying to set up the ask.
People set up the ask for me all day long.
I see it all day long.
All day long.
They're the fucker.
I'm so glad you fucking took that advice.
And you're right, that
is why you're happy.
- [Alex] Yeah.
Week one it was crazy
'cause I had a goal for sales.
The week before I was like 40% there.
- So you were nervous.
- [Alex] Terrified.
I was like back against the
wall trying to close deals.
- Where did the number come from?
'Cause it's always arbitrary.
- [Alex] It all came through at that week.
- No, no, where did you come
up with the fucking number?
- [Alex] Just talking to people.
You know, they say like
30,000 gets you this,
10,000 gets you this.
- So what was your number?
- [Alex] It was 10.
I was shooting for 10 week one.
- I love you for that because to me
knowing you from afar,
and obviously intimately
in your early days and
things of that nature,
that's a very realistic number.
You pleasantly just surprised me
and that doesn't happen to me often.
I'm proud of you, man.
That's really good.
- [Alex] Thank you.
- Okay so you're at 4,000
and you're like, "Fuck!"
- [Alex] Dude my publisher
is printing 5,000 copies.
But I'm like, my goal's 10,000, you know.
And at the last second they
had to do three reprints.
I hit 10,000 week one.
- That's awesome.
- [Alex] And dude I know
you do that like in a day
before the book comes out.
- I do but I'm much better than you.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- Dude, it's true.
You're 10 years into the game.
- I'm better, of course, dude.
Dude, I'm super proud of
you on the 10,000 thing.
- Wait, so you're gonna do another book?
- Well right now it's a month in.
- Okay, you're a month in.
- I'm a month in.
And the most surprising thing, man,
not just the, okay, look,
there's people who didn't hook it up
the way I hoped they would hook it up.
- That's right, and by
the way, there's hope,
and then there's expectation.
My hope is that everybody like, yeah,
they buy 80,000 pairs of sneakers.
I hit him up, I'm like yo let's go hard.
He's like, "Yo, bro, I'm not"
you know, 'cause I'm
thinking about the flip game
and everything, I hit him up
because I'm like he's really,
and he's like, "Yo, I can't buy
"1000 or 100 or your sneakers."
I'm like I get it.
I never, there's always hope.
Like the reason I wrote
Jab, Jab, Right Hook,
it's so important.
Give, give, give, and then ask.
Not take or expect.
I'm super thrilled to ask,
but when the answer is no or I can't,
I'm like, you know where I weirdly go?
Compassion.
It was crazy when we had that exchange.
I'm like, oh I'm gonna fucking do,
Like that's probably why you're on.
Think about that.
The no for the sneaker like
two months ago is like fuck.
- What did you ask me to buy, 1000 pairs?
- I don't even remember, dude?
You know what happens?
I go on planes, you know
how it actually happens?
You're gonna love this.
I go into DM and I hit the A button,
and whoever shows up, I just go freestyle.
Like literally I probably hit
R on Instagram direct message,
knew I had seven minutes to
fucking throw right hooks,
hit R, your fucking glasses
fucking cartoon came up.
I hit it and I'm like, yo, buy 1000.
I don't know.
I think you're making 40
million a year on selling books.
You don't know.
And the cool thing is
when you don't expect
and your intent is pure,
you don't, it doesn't get convoluted.
When he's like, and you responded,
I remember the energy, I
don't remember verbatim,
I remember the energy of
like, "Yo dog, listen, bro,
"I supported your last thing.
"I don't have it like that.
"I'm doing my thing over here."
And I remember going
into like bet, totally.
And where my head was--
- [Reezy] You responded
in like .2 seconds.
- Because I appreciate,
first of all I appreciate the honesty.
Some people are like I got you
and they don't come through.
Two, I'm like, okay, yeah,
I so think you're gonna,
this is the ultimate compliment,
I think you're gonna end
up in such a crazy place
if you can stay disciplined
that I'm probably thinking, it's like me.
I have way less money than people think.
Way less.
'Cause I'm betting all in.
If I started my mastermind tomorrow,
I'd make 100 million a year.
So I understood it, I had empathy.
And it probably in the last 18 months
that you've been trying to get here,
you say no, nothing, for the sneakers,
is why you're sitting here.
Think about the brain fuck that is.
If that is not the lesson
of this fucking episode,
it's empathy on empathy on
empathy, non expectation.
The reason you're
smiling left and right is
there's people that probably
really let you down on your hope.
Like when I said that right
now, two or three faces
flashed in front of your head.
But when you don't have
expectations you can get over it.
Doesn't mean you're
not like to your homies
like that fucking, Rick's such a dick.
Does Rick not remember
I fucking introduced him
to the hottest girl he
ever hooked up with?
Like I know.
Like there's people that said no to me
that I put onto an investment
that they made $10 million on,
and they couldn't buy 100 of my books.
They made 10 milly.
There's a dude right now running around,
he knows who he is if he's listening.
And here's the best part.
I got love for him.
Clearly at that moment,
who the fuck knows what's going on.
I'm not judging.
But hope and expectations,
two different things.
And when you learn how
to separate that shit,
you get real happy, real fast.
- Yeah, hope for the best,
expect for the worst.
- 100%.
- [Reezy] Then you're always happy.
And have empathy.
- [Reezy] Right.
- Empathy is what you got you here.
I'm like okay cool, we need
to put him on the next spot.
'Cause he's close.
You know, like it's cool, you know?
- Which is why I really resonate with you
being an immigrant, I'm not an immigrant,
but I grew up with immigrants
'cause I grew up so poor.
- [Gary] I get it.
- I grew up in the Barrio.
And I never had anything to lose.
My parents neglected me
so I learned how to ask
and not give a shit 'cause
what did I have to lose.
I need to speak up or
you're not gonna listen,
that's how I became a salesman.
- Pride's really cute
when you got something.
Pride's, you know what, let's
stay here for a second, right.
Pride's really cute
when you have something.
When you don't have food or shelter.
It's why, you know I make
this comment a lot of
I would not judge
somebody who's got nothing
and is homeless stealing
fruit from a basket.
I don't know what else to tell you.
I can't get over it.
That is my truth belief.
Like I get it.
- You actually said that
you would steal food
to feed your kids if you had to.
- Thank you.
'Cause I would.
'Cause I'm telling you the truth.
I would.
- [Erika] You gotta do what you gotta do.
- I would.
And I would keep score and
if my circumstances changed
I'd roll up on a fucking
Bodega nine years later
and be like yo, here's 83 bucks.
And guy be like, "What?"
And I be like I stole $83 worth of shit.
Actually I stole 72,
that's inflation, got you.
Like, you know.
I believe in the macro.
It's why I'm not scared
of making mistakes.
The reason I live so in the open
is 'cause I don't fear.
I don't fear because if I make a mistake,
which I intend on doing
'cause I'm a human,
I'm gonna own that shit.
And as long as it's not
fucking murder or harassment,
as long as it's not
something serious as fuck,
I'll be able to get over it.
Yes, you'll be disappointed in me,
I'm disappointed in myself
more than you'll ever
be disappointed in me
if I do something, who knows
what can happen in life.
People are like, "You're so lucky."
I'm like until tomorrow when my kids die
in a fucking car accident.
Then am I lucky in life?
Why are we judging?
LeBron's so lucky.
What if his fucking wife and kids
going into their new home
in LA right now, moving,
get hit by a bus and they die forever.
Is LeBron fucking lucky?
Fuck you.
Stop judging.
Right, you eliminate judgment,
you will fucking live.
Fucking judgment is the poison
of our society right now.
So much judgment.
You don't know what's going
on in somebody's home.
- [Alex] Definitely.
I think that--
- Buy Alex's book, by the way.
Let's get him 10,000 tomorrow.
Link that shit in the fucking,
let's really fucking humble him
and make him realize how much
better I really am than him
that one right hook in my podcast
late into the episode with a right hook
sells more than his whole
fucking life tried to sell.
Buy his fucking book.
I guarantee it's good.
I will never read it.
But I never give people daps.
But this guy, he's a good kid.
I like the way he's doing it.
- Do you do an audio version?
- Oh yeah, I recorded it too.
- You recorded it yourself?
- Yeah.
- Good job.
I absolutely hate it when people
don't read their own audio book.
- It was actually the most
fun part of the whole process,
the audio part.
- Last thing you want everybody to know
'cause we gotta bounce, I
got a ton of shit to do,
I gotta go see my family.
Erika.
- Thanks for having us.
Buy Rough 'N Rowdy next Sunday night.
- How much is it?
- It is right now $15.99.
It'll be $19.99 night of.
- That's how you do it.
- We did an early bird special.
There was a bunch of (mumbling)
who got the whole season for $6.99
'cause we didn't know.
- Oh, that's fucking amazing.
- [Erika] It's so fun.
- Good for them.
Do you know that's what I do?
By the way, did you do that?
Are you gonna do a book you think,
like an official book at some point?
- Yeah, I'm working on it.
- So I do the best thing.
When I sell sneakers or books
I come up with these secret packages
and everybody shits on me
who wants to shit on me
and I laugh because I always know that,
and Tyler's probably laughing right now,
so cool, buy 10 sneakers,
I'll probably do one more
surprise for sneakers.
Buy 10 sneakers, 1000
bucks, buy 10 sneakers,
send me your receipt,
I'm gonna get you by the end of the year,
you don't know what's gonna happen.
I laugh because the
level of work we put in
to giving people something
that's worth more
than what they bought for $1000
is like my obsession.
I love the surprise.
- The game of it is awesome.
- When you did the
preview and it was $6.99,
they're like, "We don't
know what we're gonna get."
- And people are like,
"You're such an idiot.
"People are stealing from you."
And I'm like I hope they steal from me.
- Of course.
- What do you have to say?
- First off, Gary is obviously the GOAT.
Like if you don't consume his content,
at least check it out,
I recommend everybody
to read Crush It 'cause it
thoroughly changed my life.
And second--
- Is it crazy that that
book was written in 2008,
came out in 09,
like how right historically that book is?
- Oh it's insane.
It's the blueprint.
You don't need, just read Crush It.
You don't need to read the other books,
you don't need to watch anything,
just read Crush It and
if you're not succeeding
in whatever you wanna do after that,
it's your own fault.
But other than that, if
you're not happy with your
nine to five, go to
Reezy.TV and hit subscribe.
- [Gary] Spell it.
- Reezy.TV.
R-E-E-Z-Y dot TV.
- Alex.
- I was actually thinking about this
in the elevator coming up.
I'm playing around with this idea.
This is the thing, I think
you give so much great advice
to so many people, you don't
remember what you've told me.
I think over the past six years,
I can write a fucking
five page white paper
on all the crazy things that you told me.
- Do it and I'll share it.
You'll get look, I'll get look.
- [Alex] I love that.
- It's done, do it.
- [Alex] I love that man.
- Do it.
- [Alex] It'll be fun.
- Listen, one thing that,
you know I don't know, everyone's busy,
so I don't think this has necessarily hit
your three radars, but
over the last week or two,
I'm starting to really
get serious about my
throwback Thursday shit,
'cause now I'm in the game.
Now I can put up videos in 2008 and nine,
and it's been really great
for a couple reasons.
One, for all the kids out there,
when they look at it they're like,
"Yo, wait Gary Vee's been
making videos for 10 years?
"I just found out about
him three weeks ago.
"He just got popular."
It's like, oh shit, this is for real.
Number two, it's I'm saying
fucking tried and true,
like my message is not gonna change.
And so like cool, man, I would love that.
- Dude, it's been working since I was 18.
I chased you down at SXSW.
You have no idea.
Dude 18.
And all these kids watching this.
In five years they'll be coming on
and showing you how it paid off.
- Very few brands like that that you have.
- [Gary] I think that's right.
- Very few people like that.
- I know that to be true.
- Consistency is so rare.
- I knew from the moment
that I watched anything,
I was like dude this dude is legit.
Real as fuck, he actually
wants to help people.
Like from your heart.
- Endless Stamina.
- I don't know, I can't quantify it.
It's just like in my head.
Like a feeling and I was like
this guy is really similar to me.
- Doing something different.
I believe you.
- Like crazy.
- I believe you because
I see it in you too, man.
- [Reezy] Value providing, hustler.
- But stamina, that's the other thing.
- You know it's fun, I'm
looking at all three of you
and I remember more than
you might even think.
I think back to our meetings
like the business meetings
with Backstage and stuff.
That's, you know what I love?
I love the truth?
That's probably the way
I can, you know, like
there's so many different settings.
In public, one on ones.
- [Reezy] So different.
- So much communication on DMs,
like business meetings
when nobody was looking.
Actually we were probably
spent most of our time together
in that one weird two year
period when I was doing nothing,
when I was really deep into Vayner.
When I wasn't doing wine or other videos,
and I wasn't doing my vlog.
- [Erika] None of this, yeah.
- You remember the 1:00
a.m. McCafe meeting?
- The 1:00 a.m.?
- 1:00 a.m. McCafe.
- McCafe, keep talking,
I will in a minute.
I was 19 years old and I
told you my biggest dream
was to shadow you for a day.
It wasn't able to work out 'cause
HR things were happening that day.
And you made it up to me
by meeting me at 1:00 a.m.
at the McCafe next to
the old Vayner office.
And when I told that to people
they thought I was fucking with them.
I was like, he actually did it.
- You know what's interesting about that
and the fact of not
remembering it so easily?
It's what I want everybody to do.
Like just do the right thing.
When I hear that and I think to myself,
like I can see, I can be
outside myself and be like,
oh that's cool, the fact
that it's not something
that I wanna tell people,
or I think it's cool,
it means that it's just my being.
And that's just do so much right shit,
that you can't even
remember your right shit.
People are like write a
$1000 check to charity
and then they fucking promote it
for the rest of their lives.
Like just do the right thing so much--
- [Alex] It's normal.
- That it's normal.
Thank you guys, love you.
- Thank you, man.
- Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] Thanks, guys.
(hip hop music)